[Music]  what does the meanest thing a celebrity  has ever said to you Jack Shephard and  Michael Pena played a game of in a blind  spot on watch what happens live with  Andy Cohen where you tell a revealing  celeb story but don't have to drop any  names if you don't take your hand on my  shoulder I'm going to break your not  open and I will tell you that was mike  tyson which i'm proud of that one the  chip stars have been making their press  rams to promote their new buddy cop  comedy so ET brought in a special  correspondent for our interview hi I'm  Kristen Bell interviewing for  entertainment tonight I have with me the  lovely and beautiful remind me of your  name again Mike Mike Mike shepherd Mike  savings that section a separate that was  it and Michael Pena like a letter in the  smu month and you guys are not your  Christian Bale Christian Bale and we're  all in my hub kid